manassi just did The Impossible he just
beat CS go not by winning a major but by
beating face it
face it is csgo's most popular
third-party matchmaking system for top
players and after nearly eight years of
playing on it manassey has reached a
staggering 7 000 ELO now non-face
Grinders might be wondering just how
impressive that is and let me tell you
it is crazy simple is sitting at just
above 4K ELO because I was at 5.9 K and
smilia is at 6K and let me remind you
this guy is only 18. he even took the
opportunity to announce his retirement
from the platform which is totally
understandable since considering the
kinds of swings you're subjected to on
face it I think it would have been
easier just to win the major